[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui bienvenue par un autochtone si ces
milices au mollet cette semaine je veux
parler de nouvelles restent relativement
près frage de la nomination de yann à
preignan comme responsable aux relations
avec les communes aux deux personnes
pourquoi est-ce que j'ai cette passe
c'est que j'ai quand même un a priori
quand je pense à monsieur les gars de la
prégnance je pense quand même à la
clinique d'étudiants je pense quand même
au début dagonneau moi donc c'est quand
même tout notre relation à venir voir sa
première prendre un rôle aussi important
au québec parce que ministre responsable
des relations aux enfants autochtones
c'est quand même un rôle si eto'o fille
au cours de la dernière décennie
pourquoi parce que pendant très
longtemps on s'est basés vraiment sur le
texte fondateur du canada 7 de la
constitution de 1867 boul à l'article
1er 11 24
les premières nations qui sont sous la
loi sur les aides et les relations avec
les indices qui était moi l'expression
et ce serait pas mal de monde tombé sous
l'aspect fédéral et pendant très
longtemps et bien être
si tu as un ministre responsable aux
affaires et diantre autochtone c'était
quand même un rôle beaucoup plus de
relation beaucoup plus couper des rubans
et des événements et des êtres du
financement mais là on voit le rôle
s'étoffer à cause de la relation avec
toutes les enjeux non seulement avec les
communautés avec les chefs qui sont sur
des réserves dans les territoires mais
aussi avec la relation avec les
institutions autochtone qui donne des
services qui dessert la population en
milieu urbain alors cette relation est
devenue beaucoup plus politique beaucoup
plus politisé et beaucoup plus
compliquées alors pendant très longtemps
on paye des verts le fédéral y avait un
enjeu autochtone mais là de plus en plus
on peut pas ignorer la question et on a
pu le voir dans les dernières
les dernières ceni avec la commission
vient ce avec les femmes assassinées par
le code des femmes de val d'or
d'ailleurs monsieur la première était là
l'enjeu avec cette relation avec ce
ministère
ce ministre là devient de plus en plus
sensible difficile et beaucoup moins
fluide qu'avant vraiment une relation
disposer avec les chefs de vente avec
certains organismes et là on se rend
compte que la population des premières
nations est vraiment multi et cette
visite dans plusieurs aspects alors on
va parler des aspects qui touchent à la
loi sur les indiens et on va parler
aussi des aspects qui touchent aux
droits ancestraux caudroit de tentes
droite et dorion et ils le savent et
compliquent un peu le jeu et le travail
du professeur
cependant il faut comprendre
il est présentement une nomination ici
un rôle de relations avec les
communautés autochtones peut être
extrêmement problématique est
extrêmement censé mettre une claque
énorme sur une campagne où on veut faire
parler de racisme systémique on met
quand même un représentant de force
publié quand même contraignant dans un
rôle où ça doit être un rôle quasiment
d'ambassadeur le rôle de ce ministre ne
devrait être celui de connecter la
communauté qu'elle soit en milieu urbain
qu'elle soit dans les communautés avec
les autres ministres comment on peut
faire que la relation deviennent plus
d'antenne parce qu'avant on a envoyé ce
ministère pour toutes les questions
autochtones
mais quand on a besoin de parler avec
les gens de différents niveaux et qu'on
a passé ses personnages on va soit parlé
avec ce mini soccer ou avec le premier
ministre ou le prochain paris toulouse
l'ancien premier ministre
donc vous comprenez que ce rôle se
développe ce rôle cette offre et comme
on met quelqu'un qui était quand même un
parti d'inquisition problématique
ça va faire le v
le niveau de stress et de tension on va
aller communauté et ce ne peut pas
négliger non plus que le rôle qui est
présent qui était présentement occupé
occupé par une femme
et là on va mettre un homme à cette
place là et en plus un homme non
autochtone et j'ai même pas un homme
raciste et un nom autochtone et là on
peut comprendre que ce racisme système u
vient nous mettre en face justement
cette relation qui était si est-ce que
c'est parce qu'on veut mettre un peu
soldats américains il va aller lutter
pour nous ou est ce que c'est vraiment
parce que la personne a des capacités
qui je pense sont démontrés quand même
un certain niveau qu'en fait de la
commission indienne mais c'est très très
difficile parce que là on se porte
est ce que c'est un champ miné où est ce
que c'est vraiment on met quelqu'un il
va prendre d'avancé
toutes ces enjeux là et les réfléchir et
savoir communiquer avec les communautés
autant sur les réserves que dans les
milieux urbains et il faut pas négliger
que d'avoir une femme qui en commun et
tafer la relation avec les centres
d'amitié par exemple avec les services
se trouvent en milieu urbain c'est
important et par le passé extrêmement
masculin et donc on voyait quand même
peu d'espèces de boli square où est ce
que c'est très difficile après d'avoir
la voix des femmes entendu le traverso
bien sûr on fait confiance le plus
possible à nos chefs ont fait plus de
confiance possible à nos ministres mais
on s'entend que la confiance est très
dur à donner présentement on peut pas
faire des votes de confiance quand on
vient des communes autre tome puisque on
se fait constamment échaudé comme des
chats alors je suis très très très
curieux de voir comment ça va se
développer je suis très curieuse aussi
de voir comment mais sur la première
vont prendre ce rôle et soit vraiment
l'échappée et ils répondent à l'ironie
de ce que le message envoie ou est ce
que justement parce qu'il a
quelqu'un qui le surveille ça de la
commune autocollants complet est-ce
qu'il va peut-être aller plus loin
encore dans cette relation se développer
quelque chose que personne n'avait
développé auparavant au niveau
provincial
donc ce sera c'est intéressant gardez
les yeux ouverts
suivez les enjeux et comprenez pourquoi
il va y avoir beaucoup beaucoup de
méfiance mais aussi peut-être le
trampoline pour pouvoir aller de l'avant
pour parler des choses sont ici alors
tous à peine deux semaines
n'hésitez pas à partager ses idées ou
n'hésitez pas non plus à partager vos
idées
on aime beaucoup les commentaires
constructifs je souhaite une belle scène